What is a linear algebra?
linear algebra
is actually a subset.
of
abstract algebra, which I'm going to be talking about
today.
So even though this code is called linear algebra.
We really can't have a meaningful discussion.
If we are not.
Speaking the same language or if we
do not understand each other.
because
In the context of linear algebra. We are going to use certain words
certain terms.
And unless we know those terms then you know.
We're not going to make much progress. Now. Where do we
find the definitions for those terms?
abstract algebra
So they are part of each other.
Okay linear algebra, like I said is a subset.
Of abstract algebra in other words if you learn abstract algebra,
you're on your weight. You're learning linearity.
Now in this course, there are two major components.
There are two things that we are going to try to cover in depth.
the first
category is the systems of linear equations.
one of the very
impressive things in linear algebra
Is that it gives us techniques?
For solving multiple equations at
the same time. It allows us to find the
roots.
of multiple equations at the same time
why is that important well and
you know, what's the point of what's so important about
finding roots of an equation?
I think I'll come back to that answer once.
We go to mark down because I want to show
you some math expressions.
Okay, but equations.
Which can sometimes stand for models?
And I hope you know that models.
Are how we mathematically represent some
thing in the real world by
finding the roots of an equation?
And if that occasion happens to me a model we would
have found the essence of that model.
And with linear algebra, we were able to do this
for a seat like a sequencer equations. So
that's the first one. Okay again, I'm like we always do
in every session we start at the high level and then delve
deeper right because we won't have a
a picture
of
the discussion
the second part is Matrix operations.
This will be the bulk of the course and for that matter
this this encompasses the bulk of any linear algebra
course.
So I'll tell you what the subsets are like what
roughly goes into each category.
But here are the major components
that will be covered in both categories systems of
linear equation. Like I said allows you to or the set
of techniques that allow us to solve multiple equations at the
same time.
and
we are going to we will achieve this.
by performing
arithmetic operations on multiple rows
and what we want to do is eventually get to something called reduced
Echelon form or reduced row Echelon form.
Another part of another topic. Another thing
that we will learn is
Lu decomposition
You know the lower triangle upper triangle the composition.
and when it comes to Matrix operations we have
a set of
special types of matrices
a very important one is a is the
square Matrix and the diagonal matrix.
These types of matrices especially the
square Matrix is going to be very Central to the entire
course because Square matrices of applications
and neural networks.
in
statistics if you've heard of things like covariance and
correlation matrices
They have applications. Oh.
principal component analysis, which is
let's say our
what's the word I'm looking for it is
where we are headed towards so well, and actually it's
the slide that I want to come to so principle component analysis now,
it's not easy for me
to
like going to PC at least not not just yet.
but
If we are able to find the principal
components.
of a matrix
That's a big deal. We can do things like pattern recognition whether
it's from pictures or tabular
data or sound bites.
We it is used in stock price prediction. So
if any of you are interested in quantitative Finance PC is
actually again a very big component of
A quantitative Finance optimization optimization is
is a subset of linear or a super
set of linear program which will talk about
today but PCA will give you a powerful ability
in many different domains
that concerns data.
Now in order for us to even be able to comprehend.
How PCA works and how you're able to extract the
principle components from a matrix or from
our data?
We have this layer.
these layers of prerequisites
So for example PCA is a subset or
a subtype of singular value decomposition.
So in order for us to understand PC, we
must understand how what SVD is
generally speaking.
and the prerequisite for understanding SVD
is knowing something called a characteristic polynomial.
The determinant function from which we can
extract eigenvalues and eigenvectors. I have a good sense. You
most of you heard of eigenvales and eigenvectors.
Okay.
And of course, we can only extract eigenvalues
eigenvectors or rather. We can apply determinate function
to only a square Matrix, which is one of the many matrices that
we will encounter, but perhaps the one we
will focus mostly on.
So if you want to pick up a book.
on machine learning
all the new algebra or if you would come across a Blog and you would
to try to make sense. You know, what what is the formula of PCA? You
would get stuck at least I did.
And then I have to figure out.
the prerequisites
and
this is this is what it looks like.
So the point I'm trying to make is in this course, we're going to learn linear
algebra.
With the goal of eventually understanding techniques
like PCA.
That will then open.
These opportunities for us.
You know to apply to diff all kinds to many kinds of problems in
the real world.
Okay, so as opposed to just learning these
topics.
and abstract
And an abstract matter we want to see how every single
concept applies to practical problems.
And we will do this with python. So you will Implement some
of these not or not. We cannot Implement all
of these techniques with
python
so for example, you can we can implement the terminal
function of python characteristic polynomial is a
little bit more.
challenging
but that's all we want to do so in this
Form you would not only learn linear
algebra an abstract algebra. By the way, you will
also look become much better at Python and specifically no
pi.